for three days the fashion world focuses
on EF and the makers and shakers of
tomorrow at runway shows art exhibitions
and concerts fashions luminaries come
together in the southern French town
their mission discovering future stars
Germany's Henning Yorker is one of 10
finalists in this year's competition
since I'm an avid guns it's really great
for me and for my work to be shown in
such an international and professional
context hasn't Hansen and to get
feedback from people who are in that
part of the industry de Victor's of a
season of I scorn
New York I was selected from 350
applicants the 28 year old studied
fashion design at the Berlin University
of the Arts his graduation collection
was the basis for the seven looks he'll
be showing at the festival IDI is the
idea is a party in the 1920s I've also
worked with elements like a roll of
wrapping paper which makes you think of
balloons I've got a lot of inspiration
from Jeff Koons balloon dog the
connection between art and fashion is
one of the hallmarks of the EF festival
it takes place at the Villa Noi
overlooking the town since it was built
in the 1920s the Bauhaus style building
has been a place for artists to meet and
share ideas
this year's jury President Felipe
Oliveira Batista is the creative
director of Lacoste his career began
when he won the competition ten years
ago we're looking at us and most of it
is someone people that have like very
clear vision as well of what they're
about so we're looking above all as well
of you know very individual statements
and because it's you know you have to
yeah you have to stand out in my head
for Henning yoga and his fellow
finalists this is a massive opportunity
to hit the big time but three shows in
three days is a huge challenge primarily
on the logistics front now the stress is
building up with all the packing and
transportation there's no time to take a
break there's no better stage for the
finalists to showcase their talents to
the industry's top names you have to be
creative and still we are an industry so
we need to integrate talents and select
them carefully there's also an award for
best emerging photographer
as ever the aim of the air is to bring
together artists from all manner of
disciplines the appearance of Radiohead
bassist Colin Greenwood is no
coincidence that's one of my favorite
things about being a musician is the
fact that I've made music they'll help
to make music that other people listen
to and becomes part of the fabric of
their lives is amazing a few kilometers
away the all deciding fashion show is
being held in this renovated barn the
ten young designers are making their
final preparations meanwhile the first
guests are arriving and Henning Yoga is
getting excited it's what suppose you
are experiencing the moment of the
fashion show there's also a lot of
adrenaline involved the most important
guests are the jury headed by Portuguese
fashion designer Philippe Oliveira
Baptista then comes the moment of truth
for Henning Yorker in his collection
called celebration
the ten contestants compete for several
prizes the main one the comp leader
Julie comes with a 15,000 euro purse and
this year's big winner is
satu Marilyn from Finland it's been
great just to be here and I think lots
of things are going to happen now for
all the young designers present just
making it to the finals of the EF
fashion festival was a big step on the
road to stardom